hello john perry here today we are going
to have our final
video
on random mutations our mutations really
random again this question comes from
aki he wanted to know about this new
nature paper about random mutations what
this paper claims is that mutations are
not always as random as we thought that
they were today we're going to dive deep
into this paper itself and the history
of evolutionary thought to see
exactly how much this new discovery
clashes with what we thought we knew
about evolution this paper has made a
huge splash in the news
here's an article about the paper saying
dna mutations are not random new
research radically changes our
understanding of evolution new study
provides first evidence of non-random
mutations in dna study challenges
evolutionary theory that dna mutations
are random now let's suppose for a
moment that those aren't just
click-baity headlines and that they
actually accurately represent
what was published in this paper
if mutations are not fully random
does that mean that they happen quote on
purpose and if they do happen on purpose
what exactly does that even mean
if you go around on the internet and
read what creationists are writing about
this article
this seems to be what they think is
happening
scientists have confirmed that jesus
reaches down and causes individual
mutations to happen
other folks who are wise enough to
realize that every time you see
something that doesn't make total sense
to you that doesn't automatically mean
that it's a miracle
they have a different sort of picture in
their head their picture looks something
like this people who haven't read the
actual paper but they just read the
headlines
a lot of them are thinking oh maybe
cells have some sort of a way to reach
inside themselves and cause specific
mutations when needed and if that's true
and if that's the norm if that's how
mutations normally happen that really is
in
pretty big violation of what we thought
we understood about evolution darwin
presented evidence that heritable
variation plus cumulative selection
gives rise to adaptive evolution so he
gave us evidence that things like the
eye and so on they were evolving through
dissent with modification
acted upon by natural selection
cumulative selection organisms when they
have offspring those offspring have
slight variations to the left or to the
right some of those variations will
happen to be beneficial for that
organism meaning that that organism is
more likely to reproduce than others
that's how natural selection works these
small rare beneficial variations most of
the variations that occur
accidentally are not going to be
beneficial but some of them will those
are saved up over multiple generations
while the negative variations are
discarded over generations that's the
process of natural selection cumulative
evolution by natural selection he did
not believe that these variations or
these mutations were purposeful
natural selection can do nothing until
favorable variations chance to occur
that's the word that he liked to use he
actually never used the phrase random
mutation he talked about chance
variations if we fast forward to the
1950s we hear this from davzanski he's
one of the major founders of the what's
called the modern synthesis the merger
between darwinian evolution and
mendelian genetics this is what he said
about mutation an ideal situation would
be if the organism were to respond to
the challenge of the changing
environment by producing only beneficial
mutations where and when needed but
nature has not been kind enough to endow
creations with such a providential
ability gigi simpson one of his uh
comrades
another person who's considered to be a
founding father of the modern synthesis
he was responding to people's questions
about what random means in evolution
what he does is he describes that when
we say random we don't mean
mathematically random in its purest
sense what we mean is that the mutation
isn't the exact mutation that the
organism needs in that moment and the
example he gives is this heat induced
mutations
do not produce phenotypic change related
to heat tolerance so if you take
bacteria or something and put them in an
environment that's too hot for them that
will induce mutations they will start
having more mutations more frequently
and so you might think oh well it's
trying to mutate now what's happening is
that it's not able to maintain its
genome because the heat is causing
stress on its dna things are breaking
and it's having trouble fixing them the
mutations that occur are random and that
they're not specific mutations to help
that bacteria deal with heat they're
just changes it might happen that one of
them does help the bacteria deal with
heat in which case that is called
mutational rescue but the bacteria
doesn't somehow know what type of
mutation it needs to deal better with
the heat it's just experiencing
mutations there is a small chance that
one of those mutations will help the
bacteria deal with heat but it's a
pretty small chance not zero but it is a
pretty small chance
everyone's comfortable saying that
humans do things on purpose right
a lot of people i think are also
comfortable saying that animals do
things on purpose a couple years back i
was driving my car this is in corvallis
oregon and there was a crow probably i
don't know
40 60 feet up in the air
and he threw a walnut at my car
and i was talking to some people about
it that lived nearby and they said yeah
that bird is always doing that he's
always picking walnuts from this tree
and he throws them at cars because
they'll run over them and open them and
then he eats them so i'm perfectly happy
saying that that crow is doing this on
purpose he's got this thinking mind a
lot of people get a little bit weird
when you try to say that cells do things
on purpose
and
i suppose i'm a little bit uh less
comfortable with that as well
i would say that
maybe you could say that cells do things
quote on purpose but little quotes
around it because cells don't have
thinking minds so far as we know right
but cells do have
evolved enzymes
evolved enzymes that evolved under
selection pressure to perform specific
functions and so you could say that
cells do things on purpose
in quotes right
darwin didn't think that
mutations were caused on purpose for the
most part and early thinkers in the
1950s and 60s also didn't think that
mutations happened on purpose or at
least that was not the norm but there
are some specific examples of systems
where you could say that the cell is
causing specific mutations on purpose
the most famous example is the crispr
immunity system this is a system that
bacteria use to fight viruses there is
an enzyme that has evolved to search for
sequences that do not exist in its own
genome and it does this physically so
you know
a stretch of dna is a physical thing and
the sequences the nucleotides and a
stretch of dna they are physical things
and different nucleotides have different
physical properties and different sets
of nucleotides have different physical
properties and there is this enzyme that
has evolved that sticks like a magnet to
a specific sequence of dna that is not
found in bacteria but is often found in
viruses
it will stick to that
just like a magnet
and then it will cut out a big chunk of
dna from that virus that kills the virus
so the virus tries to attack the cell it
inserts its dna into the cell
this enzyme recognizes that dna and cuts
a big chunk out of it disabling the
virus but then what happens is that that
chunk of dna gets inserted into the
bacteria's genome this system causes a
specific mutation in the bacteria it's
exposed to the virus in response it
causes a specific mutation
inserting that viruses dna into its own
dna
and then it uses that new inserted piece
of dna as a reference to find virus dna
quicker in the future so if this same
species of virus attacks it again it
will find it even faster than it did the
first time it's a type of adaptive
immunity
crispr you could legitimately say
is something that darwin and friends did
not expect to be discovered it's
actively causing specific mutations in
response to an environmental challenge
viruses in this case not a whole lot is
known about the step-by-step evolution
of this system
but systems like this
can evolve when there is a very
consistent problem
in an organism's environment really
complex adaptations can evolve to deal
with that problem if that problem is
consistent if it's around long enough
and viruses and bacteria have been
battling
since forever so it does make sense that
something like this could exist
but to think that a system like this
would exist
to help a bacteria solve any problem
that it deals with oh it's too warm now
oh well i'm going to somehow sense that
it's too warm
and then figure out how to mutate my dna
to make it so that i i no longer too hot
that's weird it's it's weird to think
that that's how evolution works but
back in the 80s
there were a bunch of scientists
claiming that this does happen they
called it directed mutation and there
was this big controversy a bunch of
papers back and forth a bunch of studies
and counter studies where people are
arguing about this and trying to figure
out what's really going on this article
right here summarizes the whole thing
and kind of concludes that debate in the
end it was found that actually darwin
was right there are very very few
exceptions like crispr the vast majority
of mutations are happening spontaneously
what darwin called by chance that said
it is worth pointing out that there
still are people trying to look for
directed mutation systems what did this
recent paper mutation bias reflects
natural selection and arabidopsis
thaliana what did they actually find did
they find directed mutations happening
no
no
what they found is that the location of
mutations within the genome is not
completely random we talked about that
last week this is well known for a long
time actually there are mutational hot
spots and mutational cold spots some
parts of the cell are safer than other
parts of the cell for dna to live in but
what they found in their paper is that
cells have taken advantage of this
protein coding genes so inside the
bodies of protein coding genes mutation
frequency is reduced by half and it's
reduced by two thirds inside essential
genes so essential genes we talked about
those two weeks ago those are genes that
if you have a mutation that's severe
enough to break an essential gene the
cell that suffered that mutation
will die essential genes are protected
from mutation far more than the rest of
the genome is in other words there are
kings and ponds within the genome not
all genes are treated equally does this
contradict the theory of evolution as
understood by darwin and others
not in any fundamental way no
darwin didn't think that variations or
mutations on purpose were expected
that's not what this paper found they
didn't find that mutations are happening
on purpose they found that certain
sections of the genome are more
protected against mutation than other
sections again that doesn't contradict
what people were saying in the 1950s
either so no it does not contradict in a
fundamental way how we understood
evolution however
for a very long time the basic
assumption that we made whenever we saw
a stretch of dna in two distantly
related organisms that was identical or
nearly identical what we assumed is that
natural selection
was actively maintaining those sequences
so every time there was a mutation
the organism that suffered that mutation
would die or eventually their
descendants would be out competed by the
descendants of their neighbors we
believe that natural selection was
actively
maintaining those sequences and now we
know that's not necessarily the case
those sequences might just have a much
lower mutation rate and that is why they
don't change very much even over
evolutionary time so the findings of
this paper don't fundamentally challenge
the theory of evolution but they do they
do challenge a long-held assumption
within the theory of evolution this here
is my favorite image from the paper my
favorite diagram i liked it so much that
i actually redesigned it in my style
they give us a loaded dice analogy
evolution at its core really is still a
game of chance but the way that
evolutionary dynamics have played out
over the years has skewed the odds in
the organism's favor
this allows fewer miscarriages by making
the nastiest types of mutations very
very rare
does this new study provide the first
evidence of non-random mutations in dna
non-random in the sense that we're
talking about here in that different
parts of the genome mutate at different
rates and that natural selection is
taking advantage of that fact and
actually putting important genes in safe
spots no this is definitely not the
first paper that figured this out back
when i first started teaching evolution
i made the mistake
that a lot of people make
and assuming that mutations are
completely random within the genome
and i had made a video i can't remember
which video it was
but in that video i specifically said in
in the script mutations are completely
random and happen anywhere within the
genome
and when i was showing it to
one of my old college professors
he was like whoa
no you got to check out this paper right
here a paper published in 2004
functional bias and spatial organization
of genes in mutational hot and cold
regions in the human genome first off we
have known for a very long time that
there are mutational hot spots and
mutational cold spots in organisms
genomes we've known that since like
1960s but it's been debated whether or
not natural selection ever exploits that
fact and right here in 2004 this paper
says that yes natural selection does
exploit this and they gave evidence
pretty good evidence suggesting that in
humans our most important genes happen
to be located in the safest spots of our
genomes and last week i talked about a
mechanism that could cause that so if we
already knew this then what does this
new paper really even tell us well first
off they did huge real-time experiments
on mutation rates that paper from 2004
that convinced me that i needed to edit
my video my biology professor was
convinced of that as well but not
everyone in the scientific community was
this new paper what they did is they
performed a huge real-time experiment on
mutation rates they looked at how
mutations happen in real time to make
sure that important genes really were
mutating less than the rest of the
genome second they proposed a mechanism
they gave pretty good evidence showing
how it is that they think cells are
actually doing this physically and then
finally they demonstrated mathematically
that normal natural selection can easily
cause what they found so what was their
proposed mechanism last week i talked
about translocation mutations and
transposition mutations we've long
suspected that these types of mutations
these are types of mutations that take
chunks of dna and move them to new spots
in the genome if these are happening
just by accident all over the place if
one of these translocation mutations
happens to move a really important gene
into a safer spot of the genome
the mother who has that mutation when
she has offspring she's less likely to
have miscarriages and therefore natural
selection can promote that mutation that
translocation mutation that's very
likely one of the important mechanisms
that allows genomes to evolve in this
way but the new mechanism that was
proposed it's not totally new it's
actually 10 years old but they
they found a lot of supporting evidence
for this dna is not just loosely hanging
out inside of a cell it's wrapped around
protein complexes called histones and
when a gene gets used by the cell a
bunch of different proteins clamp onto
it and they make a copy of it into rna
and then that rna is used for something
maybe it becomes a functional part of a
ribosome or maybe it's used to code for
protein
but when a gene is being used
histones are chemically modified and
they're chemically modified in a
reversible way little molecules get
stuck to them and we call these
epigenetic markers and because these
epigenetic markers get stuck to genes
that are being used a lot researchers
who worked on this new paper 10 years
ago they suggested that maybe some of
our dna repair proteins the proteins
that scan dna for
little nicks and breaks and fix them
maybe some of those have evolved the
ability to recognize these little
markers maybe they stick to them and if
so
that would mean
that genes that are used more often get
more protection from the cell they have
more access to these repair mechanisms
they suggested that 10 years ago and
then they found evidence for it here in
this paper pretty strong evidence that's
really really cool
and then finally they demonstrated
mathematically that normal natural
selection can easily cause what they
found and that demonstration was
actually 10 years ago in the 2012 paper
this is the paper non-random mutation
the evolution of targeted hypermutation
and hypomutation and that was a really
important paper because there were
debates from people who work strictly in
theory in these mathematical models of
evolution suggesting that even though
there are variable mutation rates
in the genomes of organisms there
probably isn't enough selection pressure
to allow natural selection to take
advantage of this fact this paper 10
years ago was a rebuttal to that they
said actually this could happen
especially if you had a mechanism that
allowed genes that are used a lot to
have more access the cell's repair
systems you could easily get the
evolution of hypomutation so slowed down
mutation in
essential genes so that is what this
paper has found it's a really cool paper
most of what's here is is not new
especially it's not completely new but
they really did demonstrate once and for
all i mean it's very very hard to argue
with the data that they've presented yes
not only does natural selection weed out
mutations when they do happen in
essential genes but mutations actually
happen less often and this protection
evolved it evolved through the normal
process of descent with modification
acted upon by natural selection they
have this gem of a line here right
before the conclusion they say while
perhaps initially surprising our
synthesis between epigenomics so those
little tags that i was telling you about
and population genetic theory predicts
that the observed bias could readily
arise
via natural selection
before closing
i want to
point out something that
they talked about really briefly they
barely touched on it in this paper i
think they're probably going to publish
a paper that goes way more in depth
later but i want to point something out
about this system that they found this
mechanism that they found these
epigenetic markers
these changes in the histones that
happen when a gene is used a lot those
are
temporary in genes that are constantly
being used those are constantly being
put back on them those tags are
but in genes that are not used very
often those will eventually dissipate
what this means
is that if for multiple generations a
specific gene is not being used the cell
will stop protecting that gene from
mutation
basically what these people have
discovered is a real-time sensor which
tattletails on jeans for slacking off
freeloaders get mutated
that is really cool that is really cool
i hope that they continue investigating
down this line
i'm curious to see how the dynamics of
this system play out in real life
with what i just told you there i don't
know how
that would translate back into the
germline very well in fact i don't know
that it would at all maybe it wouldn't
at all maybe this would only be
beneficial in single-celled organisms
but
super interesting to think about
so
there you have it folks our mutations
random
yes they are random in the sense that
with very very few exceptions
mutations do not happen quote on purpose
as gigi simpson said heat induced
mutations do not produce phenotypic
change related to heat tolerance
they just produce change as dobzhansky
said an ideal situation would be if the
organism were to respond to the
challenge of the changing environment by
producing only beneficial mutations
where and when needed but nature has not
been kind enough to endow creations with
such a providential ability
so far as we know those claims are still
true
there are a few exceptions like crispr
that violate those claims but they are
very very few mutations are random and
that they do not happen quote on purpose
however they are not completely random
and that they don't happen
perfectly randomly in any location in
the genome and natural selection has
taken advantage of this there are kings
and there are pawns
in the genome
aki
i hope that answers your question
so long for now